nos dicen determina para cada valor de x
si está en el dominio de f o no ya que
tenemos la definición de fx así que
pausa el vídeo y observa si puedes
resolverlo por tu cuenta antes de que lo
hagamos juntos muy bien solo como un
pequeño repaso si x está en el dominio
de nuestra función significa que si
ponemos a nuestra x en la función
entonces vamos a obtener un valor de
salida definido para efe de x
pero si por cualquier razón efe no está
definida para x y obtenemos algún tipo
de estado indefinido
entonces x no estará en nuestro dominio
bueno intentemos estos distintos valores
estará x igual a menos 5 en el dominio
de f bien veamos qué pasa si intentamos
evaluar
efe 5 bueno en nuestro numerador
tendremos menos cinco más cinco en cada
lugar que veamos una x la vamos a
reemplazar por menos 5 menos 55 entre
menos 5 menos 3 lo cual es igual a bueno
en el numerador obtenemos 0 y en el
denominador obtenemos menos 8 ahora al
principio ves el 0 y puede que te
preocupes un poco pero este es el cero
en el numerador así que todo esto se
evalúa en cero que es
un valor de salida completamente válido
por lo tanto x igual a menos 5 está en
el dominio que hay de x igual a 0 está
en el dominio bueno pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo
bueno para f de 0 tenemos en nuestro
numerador 05 y en nuestro denominador
tenemos cero menos 3 lo cual nos da 5 en
el numerador y menos 3 en el denominador
lo que es menos 5 tercios este es un
valor de salida completamente válido por
lo tanto la función está definida en x
igual a 0
por lo tanto ten por seguro que estamos
en el dominio
ok y ahora que hay de x igual a 3 pausa
el vídeo e intenta averiguarlo
lo voy a hacer por acá arriba efe de 3
es igual y puede que ya estés viendo
algunas señales de alarma en cuanto a lo
que sucederá aquí en el denominador pero
voy a evaluar toda la expresión así que
en el numerador tengo 35 y en el
denominador tendré 3 menos 3 lo cual nos
da 8 entre 0 ahora cuánto es 8 dividido
entre 0 no lo sabemos
esta es una de las cosas fascinantes de
las matemáticas no hemos definido qué es
lo que pasa cuando algo está dividido
entre 0 por lo tanto tres no está en el
dominio la función no está definida no
está en el dominio
muy bien hagamos otro ejemplo determina
para cada valor de x si está en el
dominio de g o no bien pausa el vídeo e
intenta trabajar con estos tres muy bien
en primer lugar cuando x es igual a
menos 3 obtenemos un valor definido en
que de x 73 si intentamos evaluar esto
nos queda como la raíz cuadrada de 3 x
menos 3 lo cual es la raíz cuadrada de
menos 9 y bueno cuando tenemos una raíz
principal como ésta no sabemos cómo
evaluarla por lo tanto no está en el
dominio
ok que hay cuando x es igual a cero
bueno g de cero es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de tres por cero que es la raíz
cuadrada de cero que es cero por lo
tanto obtenemos un resultado correcto
entonces está en el dominio y que hay de
g de 2
cuando x es igual a 2 obtenemos un g2
válido bueno que de 2 es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 3 x 2 y es lo mismo que la
raíz cuadrada de 6 que es un valor de
salida definido para g entonces x
igualados está también en el dominio ok
hagamos un último ejemplo
nos dice determina para cada valor de x
si está en el dominio de h o no bien
pausa el vídeo e intenta averiguarlo
bien primero pensemos en hd menos 1 a
que será igual bueno esto es lo mismo
que menos 1 cada vez que veamos a x la
sustituiremos x menos 1 menos 15 esto
elevado al cuadrado lo cual es menos 6
elevado al cuadrado lo cual es 36 que es
un valor de salida válido así que en
definitiva está en el dominio
qué hay de 5 bueno a 75 es igual a 55 al
cuadrado y podrías estar preocupándote
porque ves un cero aquí pero esto no es
dividir entre cero es elevar cero al
cuadrado lo cual es completamente válido
pero al cuadrado es simplemente cero por
lo tanto h de 5 está muy bien definido y
por lo tanto está en el dominio
ahora que hay de 8 de 10 bueno h de 10
es igual a 10 menos 5 al cuadrado que es
igual a 5 al cuadrado que es 25 y una
vez más es un valor de salida correcto
entonces en definitiva la función está
definida en x igual a 10
hemos acabado